minus carlson to get ready to talk with
us and here he is magnus carlsen
huge congratulations on reaching the
final
thank you we did see a big smile on your
face when this
uh eventually ended you clapped a little
bit can you tell us
uh what sort of emotions it brings to
you to to reach the final after a
dramatic day
um no i would have to say uh this was
very very different from the match
against dubov
um i felt in that match
i uh um made it very very difficult for
for myself uh i feel like today
was more maxim um
playing well imposing me some
very difficult problems i feel like
in the in the second blitz game
especially i i really felt like he
put some very difficult questions to me
that i i couldn't
couldn't solve so in a sense i i wasn't
i wasn't as upset to get to this point
uh today
uh just really really happy to have to
have played a good game
at the end when it really mattered so
does that mean magnus that you really
feel the form is sort of
uh rising that that it is an uphill for
you now and that you're going to be in
great shape for the final
um look i i s i'm still making
horrendous blunders in some of these
games um
but i ha at least i had a lot more fun
today than i
uh than i did against duboff um and uh
um i yeah i felt like
i i i played better uh at the very least
and i think also
my sim did did great today unfortunately
for him and
in the last game it was sort of a it was
sort of a trend that neither of us were
really
getting good positions with uh with
black and i think he just never got
going there i got a nice grip over the
position and there wasn't much you could
do
david so yeah magnus we've seen you win
twice now with white in armageddon games
is that your tip for everyone always
choose white yeah
i think it really depends on on their
opponent and how the match is going
uh and and so on uh and
uh no it's not a coincidence that i
chose white against two
uh very aggressive and sharp players
and uh yeah to me again it was was
obvious i
i struggled mightily with uh with black
in the last couple of games against him
um and i thought yeah uh
a minute up an interesting position
um should sort of uh should certainly be
fine
um i mean i thought if
it comes to that i can plan b still flag
him so
um it felt like a really obvious choice
today
to go for white hmm and that mine is
it's wesley so waiting for you
in that final what you expect from that
uh certainly a very tough fight
uh lost to him and um in the in the
first
um in the first event um
and uh yeah i'm excited expecting
something
similarly uh tough he's been uh he's
been mightily
impressive so far in the the in the
event
i don't think he's uh he's been in in
much danger after losing that first game
to
to do that so um yeah it's gonna be fun
uh and magnus i mean uh is it only us
that keep talking about this
chances for revenge for you you got it
against do you above getting your
revenge after their things monsters
is that another chance for you now to
revenge what happened in the skilling
open and put
that whole little bit of bad period just
completely behind you
i would still say that uh a win of mine
against
somebody is not equivalent to them
beating me
so i wouldn't call it a uh you know
absolute um low for blow revenge
but certainly um
i would rather call it uh if i were to
have a good result in the final and win
would be a uh rather
a step towards uh some kind of
redemption
for for my last tournaments rather than
rematch
magnus we saw that you were very very
happy during the games and also even
before the games when you were listening
to something within
your headphones um any tips
no as i said i was just in a good mood
today uh
and even even losing some
some games didn't particularly ruin that
well i'm super curious though
what does the world champion in chess
listen to when he when he wants to get
ready for
uh important day of chess what is your
like favorite music
we'll never know you keep
bugging us with but not answering these
questions magnus
and uh magnus you said you were in a
good mood and i'm not sure if you've
seen it today we've had a challenge of
the day
for all the viewers um and uh that's to
set up the chessboard as quickly as you
can with one hand behind your back
are you up for the challenge at some
point maybe after the chess is all over
uh sure uh i don't think my my motor
skills are
are great so don't expect anything big
well we are expecting great entertaining
chess tomorrow magnus we're looking
forward to it we hope you are as well
good luck thank you